is this the erosion of the west and is
it being done perhaps through
ideological subversion
as yuri besmanov speaks about in his
work
oh man it's it's it's a it's a scary
thought because
because the following reason you know
when a kid
comes from money he doesn't understand
if the father didn't raise him right he
doesn't understand how hard it is to
make money
i had a guy i interviewed with he was a
psychologist and a planner for families
who were billionaires one of those
families was uh the templeton family the
family's worth six billion dollars
and 16 of the grandkids i think out of
the 16 15 of them became drug addicts
and ruined their lives and i think one
of them that was left
he was working with and he said i said
how can you save those kids he says it's
too late he says bad
the way to save those kids is very very
earliest what do you mean
he said the biggest challenge with these
kids is they got everything they wanted
they got the card they got the house
they got the toys they party they
were on other rich people they hooked up
with other rich people's daughters and
they went over this and they
everything came easy to them right and
then later on you're trying to teach
them character
and you realize they never learned it
there's a book i read many years ago
called ultimate gift written by a guy
named jim
stovall it's a story about a guy named
ray stevens and he's a guy that goes and
works on an oil field
eventually the owner of that field dies
he strikes oil
he becomes a billionaire and then when
he becomes a billionaire
he shoots a video that will only be
played
when he dies so
one day he dies and he is attorney that
was his best friend for 40 years he
invites him over to the house and he
says
red stevens not roy rhett stevens wants
to talk to you and he puts in the vhs
tape
and rhett says if you're here right now
he's going like this
if you're here right now it's because
i'm dead
okay and you're wondering what i'm gonna
do with the 2.2 billion dollars and who
it's going to go to
so let me break it to you he says
unfortunately i've spoiled all of you
his wife is there his daughter's there
everybody's there
so he says to my son i'm going to give
you all my properties with one exception
the janitor has more say on the
properties than you and you can never
sell the properties
but you own them i'm going to give my
investment portfolio to my daughter
but guess what the investment banker
says what you do with the money
not you i'm going to give my company to
it so he goes through all this stuff and
he gives away
and at the end his nephew's left and he
says for you
i have the ultimate gift and the
ultimate gift
i don't have a car i don't have a house
i don't have a company to give you
the ultimate gift starts on monday
tuesday when you come here i have 12
videos for you to watch
each week you're going to get a
challenge on tuesday if you take it
by the 12th month i'm going to give you
the ultimate gift
he says the reason why before you walk
out because you're upset that i don't
have any money to give you
is because you're the only one that i
didn't over spoil
right what a ridiculous story
anyways the nephew is struggling with it
i don't know if i'm gonna do it or not
he comes
i'm not gonna spoil the whole story for
you but the point is america is rhett
stevens
and america has spoiled everybody
yes let's give unemployment for this
long yes let's give
hey fdr came out with social security he
only came up with social security for a
few thousand people
he didn't come up with social security
for everybody and when he came out with
social security
the average life expectancy in america
was like mid 60s
and he started social security at 62
which means he only got
social security for three years that
means it's as if today the life
expectancy in america is 80
if fdr was alive today social security
would have started at 77.
but no today's like hey more because we
have money more because we have money
more because america's so wealthy
let's just keep throwing free money out
another stimulus 1.9 trillion another
900 billion another 1.9 trillion
to the point where in the last 13 12
months america
in the last 12 months has printed
40 of all the currency america's ever
had let me say that one more time
40 percent of all the currency america's
ever had was printed in the last 12
months which guess who it favors those
who those of you that believe in bitcoin
that's a perfect argument for you also
gold but it's a perfect argument for you
this is why the dollar is getting a
black eye right now
the more we print so for me i am
very much concerned when i see an aoc
and you go out there in aoc
great market a greater telling her
stories and just a year ago this girl
had a couple million followers on
twitter
and today she has 12.6 million followers
on twitter
and she's young she's a representative
of bronx and queens
and she has so much say what does this
mean we didn't have this kind of
momentum with socialism 40 years ago
communism and socialism the ideas have
been around for a long time since karl
marx when he wrote the book and
you know marxism communism socialism
those ideas have been on for a while
but today due to social media
people are looking at somebody and
saying wow 12.6 million followers
she must really know what she's talking
about maybe the social something's not
really not bad so then that leads me to
my concern of okay
if you live in california you're not
happy where you're at you go to texas
if you live in detroit they mistreat you
you go to
texas if you're in new york they
mistreat you you go to florida
if you're in illinois they mistreat you
you go to tennessee
so you know california you can go to
nevada because there's no state taxes
the point is
if i don't like the state i can go to a
different place i have the options
but what if it gets to a point that
eventually the federal government that
mistreats you where do you go to next
that's right you go to costa rica
do you go to dubai do you go to
singapore do you go to new zealand
where do you go do you go to camp where
do you go where do you go
so you know i would be more comfortable
if i
knew that
like if today i always say this if
somebody were to give me 10 million
people and a good amount of land a
country
we would recruit the most incredible
minds and make it very difficult to get
into that country because you would only
be able to get into that country that
you bring value to the table and we
don't care if people don't like it
but within two decades we would be the
place
everybody would want to live in because
we would build it right off the bat with
certain values and principles to protect
unfortunately today that option number
two is not very obvious
there are option number two three four
five six seven eight nine ten but it's
not as obvious so america has the
ability to bully
its own citizens because what are you
gonna do i dare you to leave america
where are you gonna go
and they're right today so if if a
handful of countries took advantage of
that
it's like working at google google
mistreats you go to facebook but imagine
if there's only one google
what are you going to go if google miss
treats you you don't have a choice
they're paying you pretty well you're
going to go anywhere else so
america's bullying right now and uh i
don't know how long it's going to last
i'm always
pro creator pro builder uh a builder's
always going to be wanted in a country a
creator's always going to be wanted in a
country
they're never they're never ever single
everybody always wants to be with a
builder and a creator
but one country or two need to really
level up their game today because
there's a lot of talent that could
potentially go to them